por qué
[Música]
una fecha para recordar el 15 de agosto
del 2021 el grupo talibán tomó
nuevamente el poder en afganistán
imposible olvidar esas imágenes de los
ciudadanos afganos atiborrados en el
aeropuerto internacional de kabul
intentando abordar cualquier tipo de
avión muchos de ellos incluso se
aferraron a los trenes de aterrizaje de
algunos aviones incluso cayeron al vacío
intentando escapar de su país
recordemos algunas de las fechas de los
hechos más importantes que han tenido
lugar a lo largo de este primer año
desde que el grupo talibán regresó al
poder en afganistán fecha importante ya
lo decía yo 15 de agosto del 2021 no
tiene lugar la caída de kabul el
presidente afgano ashraf ghaní huye del
país dos semanas después el 15 de agosto
salen las últimas tropas de eeuu de ese
país asiático septiembre del 2021 el
talibán instauró un gobierno interino
con el que regresó la temida política
religiosa meses después en enero del
2022 se hace evidente una disminución de
la ayuda internacional
sumado a diferentes factores internos se
profundiza entonces la crisis
humanitaria y la crisis económica dos
meses después en marzo del 2022 el
talibán prohíbe el regreso a las mujeres
a las escuelas y a las universidades
ordena también que los empleados del
gobierno se dejen crecer la barba y el
22 de junio del 2022 un fuerte terremoto
sacudió buena parte de afganistán cerca
de 1000 personas perdieron la vida y
otras miles perdieron sus hogares la
infraestructura se vio seriamente
afectada y también se profundiza la
crisis económica y la crisis social
recientemente agosto del 2022 el
gobierno de eeuu anunció la muerte del
líder de al-qaeda ayman al zawahiri
quien fue dado de baja con un dron
militar en un operativo en pleno corazón
de kabul la capital del país
pues muy bien después del retiro de las
tropas internacionales y también del
regreso del talibán a afganistán este
país sufre hambre opresión sobre todo ha
sido muy difícil para las mujeres que
han visto como sus derechos fueron
dejados de lado dejando por supuesto una
gran preocupación por parte de la
comunidad internacional una comunidad
que también ha sido fuertemente
criticada por su poca o no decir nula
acción para ayudar a los afganos durante
estos 12 meses que balance se puede
hacer entonces de este primer año del
regreso del talibán a afganistán que se
puede decir de esa inexplicable decisión
de eeuu de retirar sus tropas qué papel
ha jugado entonces la comunidad
internacional se olvidó de este país lo
vamos a analizar hoy en el debate de
france 24 y para conversar y analizar
este tema hemos invitado a pilar requena
ella es doctora y directora mejor del
programa 'documentos tv' que es producir
transmitido por radio televisión
española es autora del libro afganistán
y la potencia reticente ella se
encuentra en madrid también allí en la
capital española se conecta el doctor
juan veljko él es director del programa
de delincuencia organizada transnacional
del centro de estudios de seguridad
hemisféricos de la universidad de buenos
aires en argentina también es profesor
de la escuela de gobierno de university
university en ciudad de panamá les
recuerdo que ustedes también hacen parte
de esta conversación pueden dejar sus
preguntas y comentarios en nuestras
redes sociales estamos en twitter en
instagram y en facebook en donde no se
encuentran como france24
s arroba sant y luego que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta es numeral numeral
el debate efe 24 en youtube nos pueden
seguir con nuestra señal en streaming y
también aprovecho para saludar a las
personas que nos escuchan a través de
nuestro podcast todos los contenidos del
debate ya no se encuentran disponibles
en diferentes plataformas ahí las ven
ustedes en pantalla up el podcast
spotify deezer y tuning
punto de partida para este debate para
este análisis le doy entonces la
bienvenida pilar requena en la ciudad de
madrid pilar como siempre un gusto
conversar con usted bienvenida al
programa punto de partida el balance que
usted hace que a grandes rasgos de este
año del regreso del talibán al poder en
afganistán un año de retrocesos muchos
lo han calificado así por lo menos en
materia de derechos humanos para el
pueblo afgano como lo vio usted
era lo esperado por desgracia y es muy
triste reconocer que era lo que
advertimos ya el año pasado que nos
conocemos afganistán y que nos hemos
seguido afganistán en estos últimos 20
años ya dijimos que lo que se esperaba
era lo que desgraciadamente ha sucedido
y la comunidad internacional no bueno
tenemos problemas con la conexión de
depilar desde la ciudad de madrid pasó
entonces a saludar a el doctor juan
bélico también se encuentra en madrid en
la capital española
el doctor gracias por estar con nosotros
en el programa misma pregunta para el
punto de partida balance un año del
regreso del talibán al poder en
afganistán cuál es su balance de esta
situación
bueno pareciera que la comunidad
internacional optó por definir a
organizan como un lugar geográfico no lo
consideramos un país prácticamente no
hay ningún país del mundo que de iure
esté reconociendo a organista no el
gobierno talibán de afganistán como un
gobierno y los pocos países que tienen
algún tipo de relación diplomática es
solamente le han permitido a los
talibanes ocupar las embajadas otros
países han mantenido sus embajadas en
organistas pero con un perfil muy bajo y
el problema básico como recién señaló
mis colegas es que básicamente la
comunidad internacional tiene otras
prioridades en este momento el
afganistán salió de los titulares además
es un conflicto difícil de resolver
porque tienen más de cuatro siglos de
historia en muchos y muchos actores
externos han intentado resolver un
problema que tiene muy difícil solución
y se han gastado fortunas en este tema y
realmente no se ha llegado a ningún
resultado por el contrario yo creo que
hoy estamos peor que en el 2001
doctor continúo con usted para
profundizar sobre este tema hablemos de
la situación al interior del país cómo
están viviendo los afganos yo daba
algunas luces en la introducción de el
programa es muy complicada la situación
alimentaria es supremamente difícil la
situación económica y ni que decir de la
situación de las mujeres vamos a tratar
el tema de las mujeres un poco más
adelante porque merece la pena ver lo
que está sucediendo allí y cómo es la
situación allí como es el día a día de
los afganos en la situación que están
viviendo
pero como mencioné recién siendo un
lugar geográfico y no un país reconocido
con un gobierno reconocido esta no tiene
acceso al crédito internacional no tiene
acceso a las transacciones financieras
internacionales por lo tanto por lo
tanto su economía está viviendo como una
isla y solamente se maneja a través de
carriles informales con economía
informal sobre todo el presupuesto está
financiado en este momento por una
exportación no muy transparente de
carbón a pakistán su país vecino
mayoritariamente y el otro tema bastante
preocupante es el opio a ver el
organista no era productor antes de la
retira de eeuu de prácticamente 63 por
ciento de lo que se consumía en el mundo
en este momento está en el 85 por ciento
a esto hay que agregarle según sea un
mundial de la salud un 95 por ciento de
la población está padeciendo hambre para
dimensionar
recién y como si esto fuera poco tenemos
una actividad económica prácticamente
nula con un nivel de inflación salvaje y
brutal y además con una buena parte de
la población siendo el comentario que
hizo sobre el tema de las mujeres que
están prácticamente capacitadas de
participar de la mía el desempleo es
altísimo la poca gente que tiene algún
recurso económico están vendiendo a
deshaciéndose de sus bienes para buscar
empleo en los países vecinos por ejemplo
irán no lo han conseguido y han
retornado con el agravante de que ahora
no tienen el bien que han vendido para
poder salir del país entonces tenemos un
país con 40 millones de personas 3
millones que ya han salido y el otro 7
que están buscando la manera de salir y
generando una crisis es básicamente
bastante grave en materia migratoria
y obviamente va a dejar un penal de
problemas domésticos porque normalmente
que abandona la casa primero es el que
sostiene la familia y queda el resto de
la familia sin ningún tipo de sostén con
lo cual la crisis socioeconómica se va a
agravar más todavía en el futuro
en este país doctor delicado tiene la
particularidad que varía mucho de los
centros urbanos de las pocas ciudades
grandes que hay con algo de
infraestructura y kabul la capital varía
mucho también
con respecto a las regiones incluso las
regiones son manejadas hasta la llegada
al tal iván es lo que quiero preguntarle
hoy en día quién maneja a nivel rural la
política y que maneja la vida diaria
allí porque se manejaban casi que por
unos clanes es particular todavía esta
forma digamos descentralizada de
gobernar por eso es tan difícil armar
una cohesión como nación de afganistán
es lo que le ha costado a lo largo de
todos estos años eso en cuanto a lo que
hemos visto de afganistán que es lo que
vemos a través de las agencias
internacionales de los reportes de
nuestros periodistas allí destacados en
terreno pero que hay de la vida rural
que hay del afganistán de las montañas
de las zonas apartadas la vida cambió
mucho desde la salida de las tropas de
eeuu y la llegada al talibán o allí es
como si hubiera detenido el tiempo
no en realidad ha sido una escuchar las
entrevistas que se le hace a la
población local a la población rural en
particular porque como usted
absolutamente correctamente mencionó
recién es una zona que tiene varios
centros urbanos
relativamente donde había acceso y hay
una gran zona rural donde la cooperación
internacional no llegaba o llegaba de
manera absolutamente limitada de hecho
en las entrevistas que le hacen a la
población rural la poca que se le puede
entrevistar se quejan de que para ello
no cambió nada porque nunca han recibido
nada ni siquiera durante los 20 años de
la presencia militar norteamericana y
esto obviamente tiene un impacto porque
hay una degradación creciente progresiva
y sigue siendo una sociedad básicamente
tribal se maneja por pequeñas tribus con
el agravante de que la crisis hace
proliferar la economía informal y por
tanto los poderes informales las mafias
el crimen organizado el narcotráfico que
está creciendo y esto obviamente es un
problema serio ahora la paradoja es que
para especificar para aclarar claramente
a qué nos referimos con zona rural la
zona rural afgana tiene una situación
geográfica muy complicada prácticamente
el 40% 50% del país son montañas
inaccesibles entonces la población
urbana no siempre tiene acceso a las
labores
digamos agrícolas por lo tanto depende
mucho de la minería minería artesanal y
la paradoja de todo esto es que
organizan es un país terriblemente rico
en muchos recursos por ejemplo uranio
litio que hoy se habla tanto sobre
tierras raras bauxita que es el
componente fundamental para el aluminio
es terriblemente rico pero básicamente
pareciera que los países vecinos no son
precisamente muy prolijos en esta
materia y admiten informal prefieren
mantener al país en este limbo de un
estado no reconocido una especie de área
geográfica donde se pueda depredar
tranquilamente y cada uno está avanzando
sus intereses estamos hablando de china
que tiene proyectado seguir el paso de
las famosas rutas de la seda' india etc
etc
si ya tengo también el tema de china en
la agenda para comentarlo más adelante
quiero decir los televidentes que
estamos intentando restablecer la
conexión con pilar requena en madrid la
parte técnica está tratando de
solucionar este tema para tenerla
nuevamente en el programa mientras tanto
yo sigo conversando con el doctor juan
bélico con quien estamos analizando la
situación quiero añadir a lo que usted
ha dicho doctor que aparte de ser un
país sumamente montañoso pues la
infraestructura no es muy buena y hay
muchas zonas del país o de esta zona
geográfica como usted la ha llamado
donde solamente se puede acceder en los
meses de verano porque en invierno
debido a las fuertes nevadas los caminos
no son aptos para llegar allí y
prácticamente los poblados quedan
aislados de esos centros urbanos
regionales a lo largo y ancho del
territorio de afganistán mi pregunta es
sobre este limbo político en el que se
encuentra el país a quién le interesa
que afganistán siga haciendo este
territorio conflictivo disputado
ingobernable o en manos de nadie como se
le puede decir ahora muchos lo han
calificado así que está en manos de
nadie la comunidad internacional pues no
reconoce quienes están allí en el poder
a quién le interesa que esto continúe
siendo así porque la comunidad
internacional prácticamente se lavó las
manos con la situación en afganistán
tras la salida de las tropas de eeuu
bueno básicamente lo que le interesa a
esta situación que prefieren no avanzar
esta situación son algunos países
vecinos que alientan la informalidad
tratando de avanzar sus intereses porque
el acceso a los recursos naturales tan
ricos que tiene organizan dependen
estrictamente de una estructura una
infraestructura o inexistente realmente
carretera a ferro de acceso ferroviario
y demás y tenemos ahí muy activamente
participando a china y la india en esta
materia marginalmente irán turquía
también estás jugando a sus intereses en
la zona como potencia regional que se
quiere proyectar como tal
obviamente rusia tiene intereses en el
lugar por por proximidad y tenemos
después países del norte particularmente
vx tan ahí recuerden que una población
una parte muy significativa son uzbekos
de estas regiones y tácticos son dos
minorías éticas muy importantes en la
región
que juegan un rol preponderante en esta
lucha inter ética inter clanes sea demás
y todos estos países quieren avanzar sus
propios intereses y obviamente si no se
logra esa infraestructura
la informalidad hasta que no aparezca y
lo más conveniente en mantener esta
informalidad porque a través de la
corrupción y los poderes informales se
accede a los recursos que de otra manera
sería imposible acceder al doctor que
avance ha tenido china fue de los pocos
países que tan pronto llegó el talibán a
acabó cuando tomaron la capital fue de
los pocos gobiernos que se acercó a las
autoridades del talibán y se mostró
abierta a empezar a trabajar con ellos
principalmente en temas de
infraestructura que es en lo que china
es muy fuerte para ayudar en el
desarrollo de otros países que tanto ha
avanzado china allí en este país en este
limbo político que hay como ve usted la
posición de china allí que además tiene
a india al lado que es la gran
competencia en la zona
he avanzado poco menos de lo que sería
deseable entre otras entre otras
cuestiones porque no tiene un
interlocutor
que a lo largo del tiempo pueda
sostenerse o sea realmente si la apuesta
de todos es que el talibán fracase como
tal por lo tanto se desgaste abra el
camino a algún otro sector que
francamente es difícil avizorar cual
pudiera ser por lo tanto es muy difícil
contestar un escenario posible futuro en
esta materia y china digamos puso el pie
en el terreno como para estar presente
pero no avanzó mucho en temas contra los
concretos porque tampoco la competencia
de china ha avanzado significativamente
entonces esto puso un pie en el lugar
marco del territorio muy claramente le
interesan mucho los recursos naturales y
además es uno de los que más pueden
adquirir tiene más capacidad financiera
para este material pero en términos
prácticos no estos conflictos internos
hacen que esa inestabilidad sea muy
difícil de la materia quiero recordar
que esto digamos vecinos les gusta la
informalidad porque no son vecinos que
tienen y muchos proyectos en materia de
anti corrupción o cosas por el estilo
por lo tanto son los que más pueden
avanzar en sus intereses en el lugar y
tampoco de la manera más democrática y
que más próxima sería o sea más
promisorio para el futuro del país es
que si uno hace una mirada en la región
puno
a pakistán por un lado que es un país
con muchos problemas políticos y
económicos una inestabilidad constante
si uno mira hacia el norte está ozbek
istán y türkmenistán que son países que
tienen gobiernos muy cuestionados por
sobre todo por occidente y bueno y buena
parte de la comunidad internacional
türkmenistán prácticamente es un país
sellado cerrado al mundo exterior
tayikistán es un país muy pobre poco
desarrollado en términos económicos
parecido a afganistán en que es muy
montañoso si tiene también zonas de
acceso muy complicado y en el otro lado
está irán que pues es un país que tiene
una relación muy difícil con europa y
con eeuu y tiene también problemas
económicos precisamente por las
sanciones internacionales que pesan
sobre él así que el vecindario el
vecindario afganistán no es que sea un
vecindario muy adecuado por lo menos
para impulsar la prosperidad en el país
o impulsar un cambio en términos
democráticos o económicos si se quiere
ver así un doctor bélico quiero
preguntarle ahora por el talibán el
talibán que vimos llegar hace un año
de regreso a kabul era completamente
diferente a lo que habíamos visto en el
pasado anteriormente veíamos a un grupo
rebelde armado que mantenía el poder
hasta la llegada de las tropas de eeuu o
las tropas internacionales pero luego
hace un año vimos a una especie
organización que daban ruedas de prensa
se emitían comunicados de prensa en
diferentes idiomas daban entrevistas en
inglés hablaban con los medios
internacionales parecía un grupo mucho
más cohesionado mucho más organizado que
estuvo todos estos 20 años tal vez
mejorándose logísticamente
y en cuanto a su estructura para dar
este golpe certero y volver al poder en
afganistán que balance se puede hacer de
este nuevo talibán como se percibe ahora
y con quién se relaciona
tendría efectivamente en lo que te dice
es absolutamente cierto el talibán en
estos 20 años ha avanzado en materia
comunicativa yo creo que ellos
entendieron algo que se entendió en
occidente desde hace yo diría fin de la
guerra fría en adelante básicamente que
las guerras se ganan en la dimensión
humana y el elemento comunicativo es
absolutamente clave en todo esto para lo
bueno y para lo malo es el recurso
propagandístico es muy activo funciona
muy bien efectivamente y ellos han dado
muestras y promesas que el tiempo
demostró que no han cumplido como por
ejemplo no albergar el terrorismo
particularmente al qaeda hemos visto
hace un par de semanas una prueba de lo
contrario ellos dicen no saber nada
difícil se jornada sobre todo cuando el
hombre vivía en kabul un lugar mejor
y por otra parte hay algunas cosas que
nunca limpian en absoluto han prometido
algunas cosas por ejemplo el tema de las
mujeres en este disco se verá más
adelante pero que en esta materia ha
habido un retroceso que nos pone
exactamente el mismo punto ideológico si
se quiere metodológico anterior si han
tenido un poco más de estructuración
interna y han entendido que tienen que
realizar un poco más el sistema para
tener control de esa multiplicidad de
etnias y clanes que en el país con lo
cual se constituyen en el gran más
poderoso de la región pero es totalmente
increíble para el resto del mundo y eso
hace que estén donde están en este
momento entre otras esos recuerdos ellos
no tiene acceso a las reservas que
siguen en eeuu y que no les liberan las
reservas con lo cual el presupuesto del
estado que era financiado en un 75 por
ciento por la ayuda internacional hoy
desapareció y encima no tienen acceso a
sus propias reservas con lo cual están
en una situación de desgaste yo diría
muy grave y que la economía informal no
va a poder suplir se recordemos que el
precio hay que mantener un sistema
judicial sistema el defensa que
obviamente no lo pueden financiar de
ninguna manera en ese orden de ideas
doctor con quién se relaciona
internacionalmente el talibán con quien
recibí apoyo quien apoya a este gobierno
interino que es reconocido por pocos a
nivel internacional y que tanto apoyo
tiene a nivel local
apoyo local parece que hay algo de apoyo
local pero partir yo me centraría en las
zonas urbanas también hay que reconocer
que ese apoyo es parcial hay gente que
está conforme con que ya la gran guerra
haya terminado ahora eso a costa de
sacrificar libertades que tampoco la han
tenido demasiado durante el período de
la ocupación tanto soviética como
norteamericana por lo cual francamente
en
las aspiraciones de los sectores urbanos
digamos más modernistas más modernizados
hay una profunda decepción con todo esto
en las áreas rurales es muy difícil
establecer los para ellos nada cambio
por el contrario el acceso a la
información que tenemos desde la
comunidad internacional de lo que ocurre
en las zonas rurales es prácticamente
nula y todo hace suponer que las
situaciones más las organizaciones
médicos sin fronteras reporta una crisis
sanitaria terminal y que la cosa no está
mejorando y además de no recibir ayuda
internacional están faltando
medicamentos son tenidos desastres
naturales usted mencionó en la
presentación recién que los ponen en una
situación extremadamente crítica
entonces esa economía de súper
y lo que falta que pueda caer esa
economía porque la situación todavía no
ha llegado al fondo así dicen los
expertos y conocedores de este tema creo
que por fin tenemos a pilar en la ciudad
de madrid tenemos el audio de ella pilar
bienvenida nuevamente al programa por
fin la tenemos ya conectada le hago una
pregunta general entonces para que se
unan a esta conversación estamos
hablando del apoyo que recibe el grupo
talibán a nivel internacional si hay
algún tipo de apoyo y qué tipo apoyo
recibe por parte de los ciudadanos
afganos que parte de este apoyo
simplemente es por esta política de
terror de miedo de susto de los
ciudadanos o que verdaderamente
ellos comulgan con esta política
religiosa y distinta que llegaron que
trajeron ellos al país hace un año
después del retiro de las tropas de eeuu
en primer lugar vemos que hay menos
reconocimiento internacional e incluso
que la última vez que en los años 90 en
los años 90 recordemos que formalmente
20 oficialmente pakistán grados árabes
unidos y arabia saudí reconocieron al
régimen talibán ahora mismo no hay un
reto
posición de ningún país importante en
pakistán china y rúsia creo que son los
más importantes
una representación talibana en su país
pero pero siempre conocimiento formas de
ningún tipo también naciones unidas se
amplió la misa misión de unama en el mes
de marzo pero dejando claro que eso no
supone eso no suponía ningún
reconocimiento del régimen talibán ni de
las autoridades de exacto como en parte
políticas y como una parte de
negociación sobre todo para poder hacer
llegar
en ayuda humanitaria y de todo tipo a
esa población que está en una situación
terrible están al borde de la inanición
en muchas zonas respecto a las zonas de
apoyo talibán
es que en el mundo rural prácticamente
la comunidad internacional durante los
últimos 20 años hizo más bien pocos
sobre todo en el mundo rural o rural
hasta recordemos que los talibanes son
de origen pasión y se han podido mover
con mucha facilidad desde prácticamente
el 2004 y el 2005 en esas zonas desde
que entraron tras la guerra de irak
porque eeuu ya empezó entonces a
abandonar afganistán
implementaron desde de nombres de las
áreas tribales de pakistán y entraron
por esas zonas y ahí siempre han tenido
un control bastante
fuerte de la población una población a
la que han convencido y a la que tienen
subyugada entre otras cosas cosas
prometiéndoles o dándoles facilidades
por ejemplo en el negocio del opio o por
otro negocio que le permita que les
permita la supervivencia naturales una y
otra vez que en estos 20 años ha
cambiado muy poco las zonas rurales
y profundas porque luego hay otras zonas
más o menos rurales como puedas' valles
como puede ser la provincia en la que
estuvo desplegado desplegada españa que
había una ciudad
que medianamente grande pero luego toda
una zona bastante rural y si para ir sí
que se incidió y sí que se hicieron
muchas cosas posts grandes no han
cambiado los talibanes siguen siendo
igual de ideológicos que lo eran en los
en los años 90 lo único que como ha
dicho mi compañero es cierto que lo que
han aprendido fundido es propaganda se
lo ha aprendido a utilizar las redes
sociales se han aprendido utiliza esa
forma sobre todo el año pasado para un
poco y ahí está yo una parte de la
prensa a los blanqueo se empezó a hablar
de los tarde los talibán radares 2.0
esos no existen pero si bien es cierto
que sí que hay una división entre los
talibanes ya eso hay que prestar mucha
atención la parte más dura no la parte
más conservadora la parte que no ha
cambiado absolutamente nada está en
kandahar que es digamos la cuna de los
talibanes siempre las conté es donde
estaba el mulá omar que es también donde
están ahora realmente los líderes seres
más sitios
de los rivales y hay una parte que busca
un cierto un cierto reconocimiento y una
cierta relación con el exterior
que no va a cumplir tampoco con lo
prometido pero que sí que busca buscarse
una sencilla adaptado porque ellos son
ahora mismo incapaces de clark el país
clase ese país no se gestiona si así
sigue habiendo la hambruna que hay sigue
habiendo la situación de desesperación
social y económica que hay por parte de
la población es a ese poblado de
rebelarse acceso después hoy hay un
cambio fundamental que sigue el pelo si
te ocurrieron en estos 20 años y sobre
todo en las zonas urbanas hay una
sociedad civil que no está distribuidora
acceder tan fã cilmente encabezada como
está moviendo por las mujeres
pilar precisamente aprovecho que tenemos
más o menos buena conexión para
preguntarle por el tema de las mujeres
hemos visto en muchos reportajes a nivel
internacional la situación que están
viviendo allí en las últimas semanas
vimos esas manifestaciones en algunas
calles de kabul en donde salió la fuerza
pública a reprimir estas manifestaciones
estamos ante el inicio de una crítica
situación para las mujeres hoy estamos
viendo lo peor que se le puede presentar
a las mujeres afganas
la situación ha sido crítica desde el
primer
por cambiado nuestro grupo cada vez que
han salido durante que han sido
definidas lo que pasa es que solo cuando
van los medios de comunicación noción
nos damos cuenta de esa represión ha
habido de tensiones también a una de las
que hubo en las últimas manifestaciones
esta fue condenada a seis meses de
prisión y tuvo y tuvo que exiliarse en
pakistán pero es verdad que tengo que
tenemos esas mujeres que no están
dispuestas a ceder que siguen tomando la
calle en cuanto pueden y sobre todo en
momentos clave chaves y luego tenemos a
las más activistas que tuvieron que
salir a forzar pasadas y han tenido que
salir también en estos meses porque si
no su vida por día de verdad grave
peligro estaban escondidas muchas de
ellas otras que salieron en el primer
momento y esas otras están haciendo toda
la otra parte desde el exterior de hacer
que no se olviden de la vida de las
mujeres de hacer que no se olviden de
azca al instante recordar
y los talibán van a pedir a mismo
tenemos dos movimientos de aires afganas
las del interior que siguen intentando
siempre que pueden manifestarse y
reclamar sus derechos y decir que que no
podemos y no debemos abandonar las filas
del exterior que constan
de los afganos y eso también lo estamos
viendo reflejado en malayo ya en vacuna
y en otras muchas óseas
líderes y de muchas ganas en mujeres a
planas y que ya te duran 20 años también
quitaron a la sociedad a la comunidad y
mundialmente no es lo que tenían que
hacer y porque veían que lo que todo
podía podía acabar en el desastre que
acabó en el año pasado
doctor ya le va a dar la palabra usted
quiero hacerle esta pregunta a pilar
aprovechando que tenemos conexión con
ella y es sobre ese anuncio que hizo
eeuu hace algunos días de la muerte del
líder de al qaeda ayman al zawahiri con
un dron no tripulado en pleno corazón de
kabul la capital afgana que
supuestamente es digámoslo hasta hace
unos meses era digamos el sitio más
seguro en ese país dentro de lo que
seguro se puede llamar en afganistán
pero pilar esto que nos dice que
nuevamente afganistán se convirtió en un
punto
una nueva cuna de terroristas de
perseguidos internacionales o siempre
fue así pese a que las tropas
internacionales estaban allí o
nuevamente el talibã le está dando
espacio a estos líderes de estos grupos
perseguidos a nivel internacional
vamos a ver durante la presencia de las
tropas internacionales teníamos digamos
des insurgencias violentas fundamentales
los talibanes el estado islámico y la
propia al qaeda pero la comunidad
internacional intentaba tenerla bajo
control lo no ya hemos visto que no
posible puesto que que terminaron
haciéndose con el poder y los talibanes
desde el primer momento
han sido a santuario de al qaeda y de
otros grupos terroristas
cercanos a los talibanes luego hay una
guerra abierta y un enfrentamiento
abierto no ha habido cubierto con el
estado islámico de jorasán de es el
estado islámico del corazón hace unos
días asesinó a un peque
hakimulá nakatani que era pro talibán
pero era también por ejemplo defensor de
de que las mujeres y las hubiesen
educación a todos los héroes no no es
sorprendente lo que lo que ha ocurrido
quizá lo sorprendente es que estuviese
justamente en el centro en el en el
meollo de la zona verde en la zona como
área protegida y más segura
y se dice y es y parece que es cierto
que era una casa de sirajuddin haqqani
que es el responsable interior de los de
los talibanes y sirajuddin haqqani es el
líder de un grupo terrorista que se ha
se ha apuntado a los talibanes pero es
uno de los grupos terroristas más
sangrientos que hay ahora mismo activos
en el mundo ha sido uno de los durante
estos últimos años y fue uno de los
grupos que cometió los crímenes y los
atentados más sangrientos también en en
afganistán es decir en la convivencia
está muy clara también cumplido que uno
de los puntos fundamentales del acuerdo
de doha que era no servir de santuario
barrió a los grupos terroristas pero
también esto era de esperar a mí lo que
me sorprende es que la gente la
comunidad internacional esté sorprendida
de lo que está ocurriendo era lo que ya
se había advertido y era lo que se sabía
y lo que fui sirviendo desde hace muchos
años y se advirtió por parte de los los
expertos o se repondrá el conducía de
situación puesto acababa en lo que ha
acabado por desgracia y la pena de todo
esto
si no se explican a los expertos no se
escucha al pueblo
y cuando cuando estamos teniendo
problemas con el audio y se están
cortando las frases pilares doctor
bélico pasó a preguntarles por un actor
importantísimo en toda esta historia
eeuu rápidamente el doctor bélico que
balancea si usted un año después de la
retirada de las tropas de este paso que
dio la política exterior del presidente
yo byte en esto tiene un norte que ya
pudieron ustedes como analistas entender
cuál era la dirección que quería tomar
eeuu o todavía esto sigue siendo un
enigma de por qué eeuu retiró sus tropas
después de 20 años generando los
problemas que generó al interior de la
otan y con los aliados de eeuu
bueno no fue una sorpresa que se haya
retirado entonces se venía preanunciando
la falta de resultados y los costos
crecientes de una operación que no
conduce a ningún lado hacía prever que
iba a producirse una retirada ahora lo
que sorprendió fue el ritmo la velocidad
y si lo bueno minerales de
desorganización en este se hizo sobre
todo dejando el campo totalmente virgen
talibanes
como dijo pilar recién no cambiaron
estos los analistas lo sabían garcía lo
había advertido los especialistas en el
tema lo sabían y lo habían hecho saber
muy claramente que esto no iba a cambiar
esta situación también es ingenuo creer
y los especialistas así lo indicaron en
su momento que el talibán no iba a
seguir teniendo relaciones y va a servir
de santuario para los terroristas y acá
se había una prospectiva posible si
habían dos rumbos posibles o esto
mejoraba y afganistán se recuperaba de
una situación en cuyo los casos los
talibanes iban a redoblar
ideológicamente propuestas y van a
ahorcar aún más a la sociedad
me queda un minuto para finalizar el
programa me toca ser la conclusión
rápidamente debo dar paso al informativo
rápidamente para la conclusión
pilar afganistán en este momento en el
escenario en el que está es un estado
fallido es un país perdido como se puede
tomar
es las dos al mismo tiempo pero sobre
todo es una población abandonada nada
debería darle vergüenza a la comunidad
internacional es sobre el otro de lo que
ocurrió el año pasado sobre todo sobre
la falta de atención hacia afganistán y
sólo un punto es una vergüenza pero está
que la otan en su cumbre de madrid no
hiciese ninguna mención de apoyo al
pueblo afgano mirad el reconocimiento de
errores y de perdón por los crímenes
cometidos durante estos 20 años
importante esta conclusión pilar doctor
bell con su conclusión es un estado
fallido un país perdido
es un estado fallido y yo diría que el
programático es bastante malo porque
convencional recién si les va bien van a
duplicar o van a incrementar su punto
ideológico con lo cual las cosas no van
no prometen nada bueno y si le va mal
van a ir a envían zas estratégicas con
grupos terroristas cada vez que
profundizando aún más su desafío a la
seguridad internacional la situación es
complicada yo diría hoy sólo
respondieron a categoría de espacio
geográfico más que un país y con un
pronóstico muy poco será peor suicidio
compilar en que si una vergüenza que la
comunidad internacional haya abandonado
a su suerte a este territorio
perfecto le agradezco mucho su análisis
para la audiencia de france 24 pilar
como siempre un gusto hoy la conexión no
jugó de nuestro lado pero es un gusto
tenerla como siempre aquí en el programa
gracias por acompañarnos ustedes gracias
por la sintonía en nombre de todo el
equipo técnico les agradezco por haber
estado con nosotros sigan con france24
[Música]